the coronavirus pandemic has remapped
everyone's worlds
how has that looked for you city lab is
an online news magazine
about urban life and places that matter
in april
we asked readers to share homemade maps
depicting how the pandemic has changed
their lives
within a month we received more than 300
submissions from around the world
using pencil watercolors clay found
objects
and many other media readers mapped a
rich spectrum of perspectives
experiences
hopes and frustrations from the places
they fled to the people they miss
to the nature neighbors and secret spots
of solace they cling to
some showed the ways their home lives
had been hemmed in and rearranged by the
virus outside
many readers infused their maps with
humor like this one sheltering in her
apartment in new delhi
and this one from california of a
relationship tested by extreme mundanity
with distractions in scarce supply
several readers turned to fantasy for
inspiration
from spain to vietnam to canada
neighborhoods were perceived in new ways
the lockdown has made people scatter
from the streets
and with them cars and noise wrote one
reader about her map of silence and
surrounding bilbao
i found myself listening more intently
as i walked and forming new dictionaries
of sound in my head
wrote another person about the sounds of
cambridge massachusetts
a routine walk focused the attention of
this reader in austin texas
i've become cognizant of the tiny
details in people's yards that reveal
things about their lives
but for a lot of people the contrast
between inside and outside felt really
dark
many maps were laced with stress and
anxiety
lonely landscapes were marked with
memories of social contact
with school closures and travel
restrictions appending their lives
several readers wish that they could be
somewhere else other than where they
were
like this college student unhappy to be
back at home
and this italian expatriate in the us
missing her family in bergamo
even if the pandemic has made physical
distances more painful
in my heart my beloved worlds are even
closer
some envisioned a better world like a
miami resident who thinks more public
transit could reconnect the city once
lockdowns lift
access to nature seemed to make all the
difference in sydney australia
a reader found herself looking closer at
the trees on her block
in the uk a writer sketched what she
called a beautiful old canyon near our
house
that looks like a lost world though each
submission was unique
put together these maps show how the
emotional experiences of the coronavirus
pandemic
have been shared by people all around
the world
as economies reopen and a wave of
protests
fill formerly empty streets public and
private spaces are shifting once again
as society struggle to balance the
sweeping impacts of the pandemic
and a massive call to address systemic
racism and injustice
as a powerful medium for revealing our
relationships to place
these maps serve as a reminder of the
ways we are still connected
especially through times of upheaval and
as new futures
are forged
you